WiTrack is a new technology
that performs 3D motion tracking
of a person purely using
radio reflections of her body,
even if the person is moving
behind a wall or furniture.
WiTrack is placed behind
the wall of this room,
as indicated by the red arrow.
As the person walks
around in the room,
it tracks his motion
through the wall.
In the adjacent room,
WiTrack outputs the location
of the person as a
red dot on the screen.
As the person moves
around behind the wall,
the red dot moves on the screen,
indicating his exact location
at any point in time.
So let us see how WiTrack works.
WiTrack performs
3D motion tracking
using body radio reflections.
It transmits wireless
signals whose power
is 100 times less than
Wi-Fi and 1,000 times
smaller than cell
phone transmissions.
These signals will
reflect off the person
and come back to its receive
antennas after some delay.
WiTrack measures the
delays and maps them
to the distance
traveled by the signals.
Based on a geometric
model of the antennas,
WiTrack can now
accurately determine
the location of the person.
The model incorporates
new algorithms
that remove reflections
due to walls and furniture
and focus only on the
reflections of a human body,
even if the person
is behind a wall
or in a completely
different room.
In this demo the person walks
on a spiral on the ground
as the red dot tracks him
in the bottom left corner
of the screen.
Note that the
spiral on the ground
is only there to show the
accuracy of the system
and is not used to aid
localization in any way.
This system has a large
number of applications.
For example, it performs highly
accurate localization simply
using reflections
off a person's body
without requiring the
person to hold any device.
It can also be used in gaming,
where it can start players
as they run down hallways or
hide behind furniture and walls
for video game enemies.
The system not only tracks
the location of a person,
but it can also
track his body parts.
In this example, the person is
controlling different household
appliances, turning them
on and off by simply
pointing his hand
in their direction.
Because WiTrack
works through walls,
it can allow you to
control appliances even
from another room.
So you leave a room and
forget to turn off the lights.
All you have to do
is point your hand
in the direction of that
room to turn the lights off.
WiTrack therefore can perform
3D motion tracking of humans
and body parts simply
using radio reflections
off a person's body.
And it works even through
walls and obstructions.